thank you
[Music]
this is StarTalk sports edition today
we're going to talk about heat stroke
why that's bad and sometimes lethal what
causes it and how to avoid it of course
I've got with me my two co-hosts Gary
O'Reilly Gary hey Neil the former Soccer
Pro and Active Sports commentator and we
borrow him from the rest of his life to
participate on start talk sports edition
and of course Chuck Nice Chuck hey Neil
that's right my longtime co-host
professional comedian and actor yes
acting like a comedian
acting like a co-host you act very well
as a comedian let me just say yeah and
so Gary and walking heat stroke that's
true we'll get more on that a little
later so Gary what have you hooked up
today the whole world has basically been
sweltering and suffering through heat
waves recently
um but what if you were an athlete and
he had to do your thing outside in the
summer months now this fact is going to
leave you a little bit cold between 1980
and 2009 there was sadly tragically 58
football players dying of hypothermia in
America so this is hypothermia which
we've all heard about when you're no
freeze to death yeah hyperthermia
correct okay so these were all American
football players in the U.S
sadly mostly in high school now yes ouch
clearly something needed to be done and
some month thankfully stepped up now on
the back of that
what is climate going to be like in
places like Atlanta in 10 maybe 20 years
time what precautions are going to be
necessary for us not just athletes
at that time will Sports themselves have
to change uh for those answers we will
need a climatologist and help us see
into the future and that will be coming
up later on in the show but firstly let
me introduce you to a lifesaver
Professor Bud Cooper clinical professor
in the department of kinesiology at the
University of Georgia
right helped instigate the heat rules
for Georgia high schools in particular
for high school football he sits on the
medical and science advisory committee
board for the Corey Stringer Institute
in Connecticut now if that name is
familiar just think it was Minnesota
Vikings player and the death of that man
was tragic uh also Rod Cooper is a
person who used science to save lives so
Neil a hero
we're all in thank you Professor Cooper
for being part of the show can I call
you bud
absolutely absolutely and my pleasure to
be with you guys today this is this is
an opportunity yep excellent excellent
so could you just tell us by the way
Kinesiology I read a book an entire book
on Kinesiology when I was in high school
and they said damn if I didn't love
astrophysics so much I'd be a
kinesiologist it was it was like it was
it was physics applied to the human body
in ways that I was just so fascinated
and so I just want you to know that I
might have been like your classmate or
your or down down the hall from you uh
in in your department at my and we would
have had a lot of fun
what goes on in heat related illnesses I
know that you know we're warm-blooded so
we have to maintain our body temperature
to function that's part of the the lot
that we were dealt at being uh human
beings so so you're saying at some point
we can't maintain it
and the temperatures that goes up and
there's nothing our body can do about it
well your body has a thermoregulatory
system that's built in it's wonderful
and and when we start to get hot what do
we do we start to sweat
so as we are engaged in activities
and the outside temperatures begin to
rise our thermal regulatory system has
to adapt to that and as long as we can
keep that metabolic balance going on
we're in good shape uh it's when that
balance is not met that we have to look
at alternative means with which we can
Implement policies or practices that
will prevent the catastrophic events
such as heat exhaustion and heat stroke
but if you're sweating of course
presumably your body needs the sweat to
evaporate otherwise it's not you just
get wet and funky so so when you talk
about heat I presume it's not just the
heat there's a humidity Factor as well
right
actually there's there's two factors
that play into that humidity is is by
far the largest influential factor and
you know down here in Georgia we we call
it the hot corner of the United States
because it is not only hot but it's also
humid but the other component that goes
into all of this is what's called the
radiant heating effect
this is what what everybody experiences
you go outside it's been a hot day you
lean against a building that's brick and
you go oh that Wall's hot or if you
stand in a parking lot and you go oh man
that asphalt is cooking basically the uh
the cooking the egg on the surface of
something that's been sitting in the sun
it is yeah
and and and we're running into more and
more of that because yes we're seeing
hotter days days that are hotter longer
so getting hotter earlier in the day and
Lasting a longer period of time but
we're also seeing that um for whatever
reason it may be we're seeing that uh
institutions colleges universities high
schools all putting in artificial
surfaces now because it's easier to
maintain we don't have to worry about
the grass getting chewed up we don't
have to water it we don't do any of
those kind of things however all of
those artificial surfaces are now
contributing to that solar heating
effect because of the manner in which
those surfaces are manufactured so
um becoming a big problem
um the most common underlying surface of
those artificial surfaces is ground up
automobile tires oh and if you watch
I've done that I I laid out I laid flat
on one of those fields and parted the
quote grass and it was just jet black
underneath little particular particles
and I said whoa
yeah you watch any of the uh you know
college or NFL games over the weekends
or whatever you'll see the athletes turn
and cut and get tackled and you see that
blacklist
which in a way if you're a fan is kind
of cool because it's what they use to
show if a guy's foot was in bounds you
see the little the little shards a
little tires
ah he was clearly in clearly he was dead
it was in yep all right absolutely so Dr
Cooper do you just look at someone and
say you need to go sit in the shade or
is is there a clinical process for you
to decide that this person is about to
enter a heat stroke
so again there are there are a number of
different things that we are looking at
not just the amount of sweating that's
occurring in fact in some cases
somebody's sweating mechanism could
actually have shut down and stop
sweating it's it one way or the other
it's not just one it could be uh either
too much sweating or profuse sweating it
could be not sweating very much at all
um they could appear very red-faced or
they can be very pale
um they oftentimes will start to lose a
little bit of their cognitive abilities
they'll look very lethargic orientation
disorientation
so uh there are a number of different
components that we look at uh I was the
athletic trainer that was in charge of
sports medicine for the Peachtree Road
Race
Gary probably don't know that one but
it's the largest 10K in the United
States 55
000 Runners on July 4th wow and so uh
you know we would obviously want to be
very keen on preventing heat stroke and
we would have medical personnel along
that entire 10K Road Race Course looking
for individuals who exhibited those
types of of symptoms and when we saw
them we would pull them out of the race
transport them to the finish line and
there we would treat them and and I'm
happy to say in the 10 years that I
oversaw that we never lost a participant
because they punched you in the face for
taking them out of the race yeah
told on they get their t-shirts so
wait wait I've got to be clear there's
something we should have said at the
beginning that we didn't and uh correct
me if I'm wrong uh the the reason why we
sweat is on the expectation that the
sweat will evaporate and the evaporation
cools our body but if it's humid the
sweat is less likely to evaporate and
therefore less likely to cool your body
that's the foundation of what's going on
here did I say that correctly isn't that
why they have uh what's it called the
wet bulb temperature which is different
for I mean uh to to for somebody being
able to withstand the Heat
it's a it's a it's a comprehensive
assessment of the environment it looks
at humidity it looks at air temperature
and it also takes into account that
radiant heat issue so it looks at all
three of those variables albeit humidity
is the most heavily weighted variable
but you're right as the humidity gets
higher and higher and higher and it's
not uncommon in the Southeast for us to
have humidity days where the humidity
level is 80 85 percent
but if you would go to you know Phoenix
or or uh you know Albuquerque or
whatever their their humidity levels are
down 20 25 so it's very different 150
degrees but it's a dry heat it's a dry
heat you'll love it so as that humidity
level gets higher it makes it more
difficult for the body to evaporate uh
the sweat off of your skin
um I just want to establish that up
front because it plays into so much of
what we're talking about yeah it does it
does so if we're if we're finding
ourselves unable to cool down through
sweating that must be affecting our core
temperature and there must be a point
where that is an indicator of
oh heat stroke or you're about to go
let's do something to prevent that or
it's too late you're already there so
how are we we being you and your medical
staff identifying that as a fact
so as a as a as a uh looking at it as a
variable can we predict it it's very
difficult uh because the best way to
assess your core temperature is doing it
rectally so we take a rectal thermometer
and insert it yep into the rectum and
that's how we get the most accurate
assessment of what your core temperature
is but when your core temperature hits
104 that's the critical Breaking Point
anything above that you are really at
risk of succumbing to a heat stroke and
that could be a catastrophic event so
um that is that is what we do so when we
see someone that is exhibiting those
um signs and symptoms that I mentioned
earlier we immediately you know bring
them into an environment that is not
stressful so more shade right remove
their clothing as best we can and we do
our rectal
um uh temperature probe to see what
their core temperature is and if it's at
that level we immediately immerse them
in a cold water tub well added their
temperature down I gotta say um getting
your temperature taken rectally will
certainly make that a memorable practice
and if you're at that level 103 104 I
promise you you're not going to fight me
on that because you're probably not
going to be conscious you're going to be
knocked out anyway so yeah so the thing
is the thing is doctor if your medical
team or a medical team is not around and
someone is starting to hit those numbers
what then collapses within the body to
end up with fatality how does this
process
but
how is it that our body can be so
sensitive to just a couple of degrees up
around there what is the most sensitive
organ to just a few degrees change
how cool again your your core
organs
you're are going to fluctuate on that
but your hypothalamus is the control
center of telling whether or not we need
to do different things so that that's
going to be the control center uh for
that going on but
um you really as an individual and
you're succumbing to those kinds of
things you're not going to know that
that's what's going on so you're at the
mercy of having medical professionals
there there was a case report of a of an
individual who had gone I think it was
in Phoenix Arizona to participate in a
mountain biking event
and he was coming from the East not hot
not dry like that area got started on
the race he was about a mile or two into
the race got off course
and nobody knew where he was and they
finally found him about an hour later
um lying unconscious they thought that
he had fallen and had a head injury and
was unconsciousness due to that and they
treated him as such they never looked at
his core temperature or anything like
that when they finally got him to the
hospital it was then that they deduced
that it was actually a heat stroke and
unfortunately the individual didn't
survive the event and that was because
it was not diagnosed correctly in the
smallest part again you know it was just
a a tragic tragic chain of events there
so now you when you call it a stroke
does it mimic
um any of the characteristics of an
actual stroke a traditional stroke a
traditional brain stroke and are any of
the resulting
um uh injuries uh lasting injuries uh do
they mimic a a traditional stroke so if
you're a look at the at the true
definition of stroke he had a stroke
we're talking about the cutting off of
blood flow to the brain
that's usually brought about by a clot
or an aneurysm something along those
lines when we look at heat stroke it's a
little bit different and that is that
the body because it is getting to be so
hot that the internal organs are
shutting down as a result of that
they're not shunting blood in the
direction of your brain so yes it it
would be catastrophic from that
perspective but it's not to be construed
as the same thing as what we see from a
cardiovascular death that's brought
about by a stroke from that true
definition
yes so so Bud we've got what goes on
physio the physiology of suffering heat
distress and heat stroke what are your
heat rules and is it as simple as gum
standing shade which by the way my mom
used to tell us when we would play
football in the back of the house where
there were no trees at two o'clock in
the afternoon in July and she would say
what the hell are you doing get get in
the shake you're gonna have a head
stroke I should have said that okay
that's that's an informed person by the
way just to reiterate what what said
earlier it's not just the temperature of
the air outside it's the radiant energy
coming to you from any Source be it the
walls the ground or of course the Sun so
if you step out of the sun into the
shade that takes away one of the forces
driving your heat exposure so when we
come back bud is going to tell us
exactly what Bud's rules are and what is
it about them that help them save
people's lives other than just tell them
get the hell out of this and other than
Chuck's mom's rules
all right she didn't get famous for
those rules let's find out why Chuck's
mom is not who's being interviewed here
and Bud Cooper is when Star talk sports
edition continues
start talk sports edition we're back
we're talking about heat stroke and
we've got Dr Bud Cooper from the
Kinesiology department at the University
of Georgia Roots Heath rules have saved
the lives of athletes especially those
in high school who get run into the
ground by their athletic coaches
and but just what what are these rules
and why should they be different from
anything anyone came up with before
so the rules that have been in place for
years was were brought out by the
American College of sports medicine they
had a position statement on uh how you
can prevent exertional heat stroke it
was a consensus position statement by a
bunch of people who are really really
knowledgeable in the area but it was
opinions they sat around okay so this is
a matter of BC times before Cooper
before before right right okay yep all
right so to address the problem I wanted
to look exactly at what was going on so
I did a three-year epidemiological study
where I just tracked everything we had
high schools involved in the study
representing five areas across the uh
the whole state of Georgia
and um we had certified that athletic
trainers at each of those high schools
and I collected data for three years I
needed to see where the trends were
we looked at everything from length of
practice to uh wet bulb low temperature
numbers to time in the season we looked
up all of that and at the end of the
three years I was able to aggregate all
that information and then come up with
policy suggestions that addressed all
that and what we saw was just what
you're saying is that everyone before
you just pulled it out of the house
basically yeah well rather let me be
more polite they did not treat it as a
study they just thought this makes sense
to me let me just put that in the pot
that's what that sounds like okay great
that would be like asking you and Gary
and Chuck as to what's the best way to
cook a steak
yeah you would all have your opinion
everybody's got a different way yes and
everybody's got a different way and my
answer is let someone else cook it
that's the best steak
best steak you've ever had in your life
that's right
absolutely so we looked at that data and
we came up with um what we saw was that
in the month of August which was the
first four weeks of football practice
that was the the most critical time
and we could see that whenever
temperatures got higher when practices
got longer that's when risk went up so
and people are in their worst shape
because they've been they've had the
previous months of summer when they
weren't doing a damn thing absolutely
and and a lot of the research that have
been done earlier showed that in order
to do justice to preventing heat stroke
we had to make sure that the individuals
were acclimatized the environment in
which they were practicing in
so one of the rules that we put into
place was that they had to have five
days of heat acclimation
no equipment all I could have on was
just their helmet practice was limited
to two hours and they would get a
climate size to the hot weather that
they're going to be participating in
once we got through those five days then
we gradually lengthened practice we
gradually introduced equipment but the
the key component was that we set up
parameters that said that as the
environment got hotter because we knew
that that was the most important uh
influential Factor when the wbgt got to
higher and higher levels we had to
change things we would shorten practice
we would take equipment off we would
increase rest breaks we would increase
hydration breaks
in order to allow the athletes to
continue practicing we didn't want to
take that away but we had to do things
to mitigate that risk because we saw
that from the the uh three years of
study of just looking at what the trends
were
so we were able to look at that I
presented that to their rules committee
I said this is what I really think we
need to do
um all knowing that that the rules
committee which was made up of football
coaches that have been coaching 35 40
years you know we've been praying
football this way forever and you know
we've been doing fine kind of thing
right right presented that information
honestly Gary they
um and and Neil and chuck all three of
you
they they probably discussed it for 20
minutes came back and said you know what
bud we're going to put every single
thing that you have suggested into
policy because there's no way we can say
it doesn't work because you have the
facts right you have the data yeah so
there's also it's called litigation
well you know this guy came to you a few
months ago with all this information and
yeah so yeah plus science just one of
the objectives of science is to remove
people's opinions absolutely and so in
fact the the the the great thing about
uh what we did was it was the first
study that looked at at the facts we
developed
a policy based on those facts and and to
date there hasn't been another state
that has done the same thing that we've
done well I don't get that so clearly
your your your uh um research is out
there you you too I know what it is
they're only Georgia rules you see
that's the thing yeah
so so be eating peaches in between plays
yeah tell me about other states yes
exactly is there do you have any
examples the state South Carolina has
has um taken a lot of what we've done
and they have applied many of our rules
to their State Association North
Carolina right similar climate Florida
and North Carolina take bits and pieces
of what we've done and applied it to
theirs but by and large the rest of the
the states across the continental and
Hawaii and Alaska have not done anything
like that at all I'm in the north why do
I need you
that's a great I mean that's kind of
funny sounding but that's a really good
attitude question right because uh you
you hear about heat deaths up here as
well
and we've had a couple of Marquee deaths
um two or three years ago we had a
player at the University of Maryland uh
that was a that was a catastrophic death
that that was totally mismanaged uh but
we've had you know other incidences at
Midwestern and Northern institutions too
so we while you see more of them in in
the South it does happen everywhere and
and we're seeing that I think mainly
because we're getting hotter and we're
seeing areas in the north that um are
experiencing heat waves again you know
the Corey Stringer Institute was founded
on the death of Corey Stringer that
happened in Mankato Minnesota you can't
get any further north right than that
area in Minnesota and it was because
they had a heat wave up there so so
there was a there was a young man that
was uh clearly he had a heat stroke uh
here in New Jersey uh I don't I forget
it was last summer but uh or to some I
forget but
um and they
they put him in the uh they took all the
ice and the Gatorade things and they
literally submerged him in that is that
part of your protocol it is it is our
protocol is to immerse an individual
into a cold tub ice immersion bath where
the temperature of the water is 50 45
degrees it is the fastest way to get the
core temperature down we need to get it
down below about 102. before we would
allow them to be transported by an
ambulance or an EMT service or anything
like that and and the problem is is that
ambulances don't have cooling mechanisms
on board and most hospitals are not set
up to do that either they have ice
blankets they can put people on but
we're getting them submerged up to their
neck in ice water and it's good any good
locker room is going to have unlimited
supply of ice right for ice baths
that's something nice on that one of the
rules that we have here you're in in
Georgia is that whenever the wbgt gets
to 86 it's mandatory that that ice tub
is on site and ready to go
what is that wet ball globe temperature
wet bulb
glow glow temperature of wbgt okay got
it right if if you've not been able to
bring organizations towards your
thinking
uh as as blocks as States particularly
the northern states have you found
coaches in northern states come to you
individually and dip into your program
because they realize they've joined the
dots and they've found out it's not a
smiley face
it is it is
um I've had I've done talks in in
Illinois and and other northern states
and they're very very interested in that
uh that they want to know what do we
need to do to ensure that that doesn't
happen and and I think that there is
becoming more and more fear because
there have been some cases recently
where a student athlete has died from
heat stroke and the parents have uh
taken it to a criminal court case and
the coaches have been charged with
manslaughter this is not taking Long
Point so I got a call from a reporter in
Billings Montana
um and and I'm somewhat familiar with
Montana I go skiing there every year uh
but they are experiencing a heat wave
currently right now with their
temperatures in the upper 90s not common
at all for Montana
and his question was the coaches really
don't know what to do
and so he sent me their policy that's in
place and the policy is uh looking at
smoke because they have problems with
Wildfire up there so what do you do when
it gets really smoky
there are also policies in there on what
you to do with uh hydration so what
should we do about hydration breaks but
it's during competition not during
practice
and what we know is that about 90 to 92
percent of all heat Strokes in sports
occur during practice not during
competition
so while they're saying we need to
increase the hydration breaks during
competition they're not doing anything
to address the times with which the risk
is the greatest and that's in practice
so of course it's not a problem until
it's a problem right and so now they
have 90 degree days with no they don't
even know what to do exactly and coaches
are not the best people in the world to
make compassionate decisions
let's let's just be honest it's like you
know I think I'm having a heat stroke
really well drop it give me 20. you know
my fingers dislocated pop it back in and
get back out there exactly but Okay so
we've got people in Billings Montana who
are acting like the British with three
inches of snow and panic because they
don't know what to do because it doesn't
do that there now this is going to
replicate I'm sure as we go forward 10
20 years time where do your rules
advance
with the climate as it changes so glad
you brought that up I did a study with
another friend of mine and he's a
climatologist and we actually looked at
the United States as a whole and looked
at average wbgt temperatures
over the entire United States and what
we did was by averaging those we were
able to break the United States down
into three geographical regions region
one region two and Region Three Region
Three would be the areas that have the
highest values that would be you know
across the southeast and you know the
South and into the Southwest area and
then the region two would be in the
center more the Midwest Atlantic Coast
regions and then region one would be up
there with your organs and your
minnesotas and your Mains and New Yorks
and things of that nature I think the
next step
is to then look at those three
geographical regions and try to come up
with better recommendations for those
schools in those areas knowing full well
that in the event that somebody in
Minnesota gets a day when it's 95 and 60
humidity and they're wearing full gear
for a football game something has to
change
and and you know the the question was
abroad early was your pushback from
coaches and there was a little bit but
you know what we are giving them an out
by saying we have things that you can do
we're not trying to cancel football
we're not trying to eliminate it we're
just trying to mitigate your risk we can
do things take some equipment off
shorten your practice
why can't there be a standardization of
what you what you've studied so that it
just becomes basically the rules across
everywhere when we reach a certain
temperature you know put these put these
protocols into place I mean that would
make everything really simple protocol
yeah it's a bud protocol right gentlemen
I think we're gonna have to go to the
blood protocol there you go no no no I
get better no way the Cooper Criterion
no sir I think it calls for the Cooper
criteria
I'll be up there at the same damn thing
and we're like Gary isn't the it isn't
the World Cup in some place hot yeah uh
we couldn't get it on the Sun so we took
it to Qatar uh
okay I didn't know the sun put in a bid
for the FIFA World Cup yeah they did
they did but they didn't win
um lost that one okay so the thing is it
goes to Qatar as long as there's not a
heat wave you're gonna be facing 80s and
70s or average temperatures humidities
in the 60s and 70 percent so what
protocols do you think we should be
looking for the organizers FIFA putting
in place like hydration breaks in middle
of halves or what do you envisage the
teams being able to do to mitigate heat
and if it does get a heat wave which is
not unusual apparently
um what could they do
you know having scheduled hydration
breaks is going to be going to be a very
critical and you know we don't want to
ruin the spirit of the game by you know
having a break in the middle of of the
first half at 20 minutes or whatever it
might be
um you know to to try to change the the
continuity of the game kind of thing but
really Gary the the bigger aspect and
and we actually see this is that we need
to ensure that the athletes that are
going to be participating in that World
Cup are acclimatized to those conditions
that's the key so uh give you an example
um in 2015 I was in Scotland
uh on a on a study abroad trip I had
taken a group of grad students over
there but I met with the Olympic coaches
for team Scotland
they were extremely concerned about
their distance Runners being able to
compete in the Rio de Janeiro games
because it is hot and it's humid and
Brazil and it's not that way in Scotland
and they were like what do we need to do
not known for its rainforests no uh no
and and you know not not to to be slight
on them but it was like should we make
them go out and train with with heavy
coats on so they can really get their
core temperature up
so the the
um the the recommendation that I gave to
the folks in Scotland was is you've got
to get your athletes down
to Brazil or to an environment that is
similar in climate so that their
athletes can train and it's going to
take them about 14 days for that to
happen so you're gonna have to pack them
up and move them somewhere where it's
hot and humid for about two weeks prior
to the Olympic Games so that their
athletes are acclimatized and I think
that's that is going to be key to any
country that is participating in uh the
World Cup okay but I have a new business
idea we create a biodome where we have
complete control over the temperature
the the radiant heat and the humidity
and we dial in the averages for the
location that people need to train and
they do it right there in the biodome I
like it I like it we actually do uh some
research in an environmental chamber
where we put either a stationary bike or
a treadmill or we can control the heat
and humidity and we do a lot of uh
studies that way but again that doesn't
mimic what a what an athlete does on the
soccer field
might be a little cheaper what's my
point yeah so if there's one in Europe
one in North America or South America
you can train there before and you then
you you want to fly the whole team until
you're actually ready to compete guys we
got to call it quits here my gosh ah I
know sorry I know it's good stuff I'm
telling you Kinesiology is the thing
these folks have the physics literacy
that makes everything makes the world go
around but let me tell you something and
he's not blowing smoke I've over the
years I've heard Neil say this several
times about how much he loves
Kinesiology yeah I'm like and I'm like
Jesus is there any level where you are
not a nerd no
well we're so we think we should call it
the Cooper Criterion and you heard it
here first
um and except Bud Cooper came up with it
but it definitely sounds good super
Criterion uh but we'd love to have you
on the show
um this is a this is a work in progress
clearly uh because we're gonna see
um what other aspects of your
kinesiological expertise can serve the
the World of Sports the things that we
brought up that it obviously we need a
lot more research done to address some
of the other areas of need as well so
excellent excellent so we're going to
let you go in this put some ice on it
put some ice on it
we're gonna let you go in this segment
but when we come back we are going to
look into the future of climate with a
climate expert from Columbia University
Dr Radley Horton when StarTalk sports
edition returns
we're back start talk we're talking
about
Heat
and we came out of the dungeon of heat
strokes and the harm it's done athletes
especially those in high school training
in in August especially in football and
there's outdoor training of course and
we thought we would sort of extend that
into just a general understanding of the
trends of heat waves and so what do we
need for that we need a climatologist
and we didn't have to look far because
Columbia University right up the street
from us has experts and we've got Lamont
research Professor Columbia University
Dr Radley Horton Radley welcome to Star
Talk great to be here again nice to see
you if you're not just any ordinary
climate scientist you specialize in
climate extremes
[Laughter]
which storm will win this year and what
is and your expertise is and your
writings have gotten you on various uh
uh national International task forces
and committees to advise municipalities
of Nations on what they should do so
let's let's dovetail my first question
to you with what we just saw in the
first two segments
um we we heard that in Atlanta Georgia
There They implemented these new rules
buds rules uh the Cooper Criterion
there's more keeping athletes alive
basically not suffering from heat stroke
is this a fact that will start surfacing
in places where it never surfaced before
so everyone is going to have to start
paying attention to budge rules apps I
think absolutely
um you know I'm talking more and more
about sort of the two waves of climate
change in a sense I think we're
approaching the point where most but not
all people are realizing that the
statistics of these extreme weather
events like heat waves are already
shifting quickly right we're getting
more heat waves longer lasting and just
more extreme than than we thought we
knew that would happen but what's also
happening I think is this realization
that it's actually happening much faster
than we thought of what yeah we're not
just getting that predicted you know 50
increase in the frequency of heat waves
we're getting unprecedented heat waves
three four degrees warmer than anything
that's ever been experienced in a place
or arriving three or four decades
earlier than we thought it would so I
think circling back to your question I
mean the once a century uh extreme event
is not happening once a decade exactly
right exactly right yeah that's that's
funny I had a conversation where uh
somebody was talking about climate
models and I said uh yeah the only thing
wrong with climate models is that they
were all right
and that they didn't predict how fast it
would happen you know so and that's it
that's it and I think it's frankly a
challenging point for some climate
scientists because we're used over the
last 10 or 20 years to hear our models
attacked climate change isn't real that
sort of thing and now of course it's
clearer than ever climate change is
happening we're the primary drivers of
it but we also need to simultaneously
reflect on the fact that our models are
lacking but in that other direction
they're missing what we call these kind
of tail risks right they actually don't
do a real good job at predicting those
lower probability High consequence
events and unfortunately when you say
tail risks just there's a lot in that
phrase yeah you don't mean biological
tales off of animals you mean yeah in a
distribution of any events uh there's
the tales of what happens that are much
more extreme than what's in the middle
so it's a mathematical tale of a curve
right that's what you're referring to
right so Bradley Radley the ironic point
for me looking at it as a former athlete
and someone who's going to be suffering
heat waves the key solution to heat
stroke is hydration meanwhile we have
extreme temperature rises we are
entering more and more heat waves and
droughts so the simple question is is
our water going to come from then in the
future if hydration is the solution to
the problem yeah I mean there's a lot of
aspects to that fortunately you know
human consumption of water is it is a
tiny amount of all the water we use it's
mostly things like mining inefficient
approaches to agriculture yeah into
agriculture but the broader yeah also
also fracking uses a huge amount of
water yeah absolutely but the broader
point I think is really important that
we need to simultaneously be thinking
about not just the higher temperatures
but how are these other climate
variables changing at the same time are
our crops for example going to be
suffering from these more extreme
temperatures that make it possible for
more air to basically get sucked out of
the atmosphere due to those high
temperatures precisely at times when
there's not as much rainfall or a
snowpack is melting earlier so we don't
have that that water splice I think your
your point is absolutely right about
shared risks across temperature and
other changes in climate variables which
by the way just in case anybody's
wondering everything that Radley just
said is already happening right now
snowpacks are melting quicker and then
we're seeing shorter snow accumulation
seasons and then we're seeing more rain
that creates runoff where it should be
snow melting very slowly and what that
does is it leads to an exacerbation of
drought so all of these things are
working hand in hand right to exacerbate
the situation but that's happening right
now but Chuck that's why we have an
expert to tell us
meteorologist show
he's making the points and he's doing so
eloquently so let's uh let's go with it
okay yeah I just want to slip in there
this notion that we have these models
could you explain
what goes on when they show hurricane
paths and they say we have the you know
our models in the Europeans have models
and they predict something different I
don't know that the public is ready to
hear two entire continents of experts
predict two things differently I don't
know that they know how to wrap their
head around that could you just give us
a few moments insight into what's going
on and how it is that an entire
continent of scientists can have a
different model from another continent
yeah yeah totally so you know how do we
all think about uncertainty right the
idea that we can have some things we
understand really well but there's
always going to be some uncertainty in
these non-linearities right where over
time an initial error in you know not
knowing exactly where steering winds are
going to be for the jet stream you know
can sort of percolate over time leading
to two Divergent Solutions so basically
it's coming down to
um uncertainties about an initial
conditions to some extent us not knowing
enough about the details of what's
Happening say over the ocean right now
but then also how the butterfly effect
as they yeah
right I read an article I took to put
this in there there's this journal I
don't know if you guys know about it
um
Bradley Shirley knows about it but Gary
and Chuck there's a journal called the
Journal of irreproducible results
and it's where hyperactive scientists
who have crazy fun sciency ideas that
are just completely inane if they write
it up you can get it published in the
Journal of irreproducible results so one
one article was was it Hurricane Andrew
or one of the really bad hurricanes the
scientists wrote they found the
butterfly that caused them okay
and they studied the butterfly in this
article it was hilarious
this whole this whole notion of the
butterfly effect that you can send the
future results of a model in completely
Divergent directions right right and
most of the time
um you know there's that cloud of
uncertainty but it's narrow enough that
it can be very useful for planning right
we can have a sense that there is a 20
chance that a stretch of the coastline
would experience a hurricane that's
enough usually from a risk management
perspective why are European scientists
different from American scientists I
don't I don't get that because European
models always stop at the less
advantaged countries and try to colonize
them personally that's what that is
[Music]
so let me ask you redley and just sort
of spin it back into
Bud's home turf as it were what do we
think the southern states the U.S are
going to be experiencing where the wise
climate wise in the next 10 20 years
because I can't see it staying where it
is I can only see it getting worse why
are you why are you focusing on the
southern states there Gary because
because it's Bud's home too but okay
Georgia ah so I mean you know I think
you know one place to start is that's a
part of the country where we also have
these extremes of heat and humidity
persisting into the evening hours uh
into the early morning so we need to be
thinking not just about that worst
moment of the day for heat and humidity
but the fact that you know if we're
nudging up temperatures just a little
bit and humidity up just a little bit
that means it's going to be harder to
find time during the day to be able to
exercise Outdoors it means it's going to
be harder for people to recover at night
to to sleep well so in these places that
are hot and humid to begin with just
shifting up those baselines
um you know will have a very profound
effect it could mean 20 or 30 more days
per year experiencing these extreme
conditions but I think it's also
important to sort of consistent with
some of the other things we've been
talking about look at some of the places
where people might not think of those
risks as being quite as severe it might
surprise people to know that the roughly
the highest combination of heat did he
ever experienced up in Wisconsin
um so it doesn't happen as frequently
but from this risk management
perspective if you're worried about that
worst event for a year low probability
but catastrophic consequences especially
for people who aren't used to it it's
definitely not just the southeast and
even some places like the Southwest very
hot and dry in terms of their
climatology but under the right if you
will conditions the Gulf of California
that water you know between the Sea of
Cortez essentially southern Mexico
that's some northern Mexico that's some
of the hottest Waters in the world by
late August early September on the right
in the right conditions
plumes of moisture can actually make
their way into those desert regions it's
not the typical day per year but if
we're not prepared even even at the LA
region can be can be vulnerable to this
so what we need to find out is not just
how these average changes in climate
affect this but what about these wild
cards how hot are those bodies of water
like the Gulf of California going to get
them Persian Gulf exactly how is
irrigation I'm gonna going to lead to
more moisture in the atmosphere crop
practices I think it's important for you
to tell just because when you talk about
hot bodies of water warming water
temperatures during this time of year uh
whether it's in the Atlantic what is
that doing and why is that important
because you know I think when people
hear about warming Waters they don't get
they don't get this correlation between
these these big storms yeah absolutely
the only thing about warming air right
that's the only thing they care about
right exactly yeah so I mean you know
issue number one certainly is the
hurricanes and tropical Cyclones as
water temperatures get above a threshold
around 80 Fahrenheit or so it's much
easier to get that energy pump going
whereby winds from a storm causing
evaporation of that very warm water
leading to a lot of evaporation you
basically can start a cycle where the
sort of engine Roars and you and you get
a hurricane
warmer the waters are the more potential
for a really powerful and devastating
hurricane and landfall but here you know
another issue is the minimum
temperatures in a lot of our coastal
regions even places like the Northeast
U.S are very closely coupled to those
water bodies nearby and in a world where
our Coastal Waters in August September
these sort of warmest times of the year
at the Northern Hemisphere start to
creep up a few degrees higher maybe in
ways that our climate models haven't
predicted well we increase the risk of
more extremes of heat and humidity and
maybe also really heavy rain events not
just through hurricanes but things like
these atmospheric Rivers because the the
surface of the ocean is communicating
with the atmosphere directly above warm
those Waters not only does the air get
warmer directly above it there's the
potential for a lot more of that
moisture to evaporate into the air where
it can cause catastrophe right either
through
if the air is warmer and we know that
warmer here can can accommodate higher
quantities of
water vapor moisture if it can
accommodate it why should that fall out
of the why does it just stay there
so let's go up and then all drop out
yeah I mean that's a great that's a
great point I think the issue there is
that it can be true that in it can so
we're getting evaporation really sort of
all over the world's oceans right and
over the Lakes but it has the tendency
to fall out is precipitation in very
specific times right and very specific
places so the evaporation is happening
everywhere but trying to figure out
exactly where it's going to rain out and
how intense that is going to be
um it's something that really can change
with climate change and the balance of
evidence suggests that
um it's those really heavy rain events
that are going to become that much worse
right so we have our sewer systems
designed to accommodate an intra to a
rainfall you know maybe in an hour tops
with climate change if we start getting
these four inch an hour rainfall events
like we seem to be seeing more and more
it has a non-linear impact right it's
not like flooding increases just a
little bit you can go from no flooding
to really extreme flooding if our drain
pipes aren't designed for that so but
towards your question I think Neil just
to sort of step back a little more I
think this is at The Cutting Edge of a
number of central climate impacts
questions a warmer atmosphere which
we're getting can hold more moisture but
it won't always right so certain areas
that are prone to being hot and humid
the Southeast U.S for example coastal
areas we can expect those areas not just
to warm but also to get more humid it's
less clear what's going to happen in
parts of the West for example right
those areas maybe get higher they don't
necessarily get more more moisture more
more rainfall more moisture in the air
but because they're hotter they're going
to suck moisture from crops from forests
this is actually a recipe for these
catastrophic wildfires and potential
crop losses and I talked earlier about
the limitations of climate models for
those tail risks now we have these
communities trying to do impact
assessment right what's going to happen
to crop yields forests
um you know just a person dying in their
attic right it's it's like a food chain
and everything right yeah yeah and we're
missing the Tails there too right
because our models inherently are too
simplistic they don't understand and
they don't understand the interactions
between all these systems what happens
when the heat wave happens at the same
time that air quality is suffering
because you're getting more war
wildfires what does that do Bradley if
you know your abundance of simplistic
then make them more complicated it's
[Laughter]
while you're at it how come you haven't
solved Quantum Computing what's your
problem what is your problem Bradley
Bradley can we throw that one back and
Neil maybe I don't know
yeah so anyway just to be clear I I what
I said was a joke I mean the problem is
and Radley correct me if I'm wrong you
could add more complexity but the range
of complexities you could add you don't
have constraints on what is the right
complexity to add and what isn't and you
could end up getting wildly off results
yeah if you're not if if you're not
judicious about it that's right I think
you know one way to think about it is we
need to invest more in uh individual
models get to higher spatial resolution
add new processes that let us for
example simulate how changes in
ecosystems as we get these higher
temperatures and rainfall then feedback
on the climate right those changes do
you need more probes in the ocean or in
the air or in the forest what
yeah that's an important piece too that
would help at the point you raised
earlier about the less the
initialization what we call what we know
at the beginning errors that you know if
we have mistakes at the beginning they
can percolate become bigger errors later
in a hurricane track but you know I
think we also need to as we're improving
models step back in a qualitative way
there's this motion towards what are
called storylines just sort of stepping
back and trying to understand all the
ways that these systems interact
including the solutions right so sit
down with with people who are health
professionals managing athletes and say
what are the things that concern you the
most what keeps you up at night and then
we think about how all these systems fit
together in a qualitative way and with
advice to do something about it Gary
absolutely a few more minutes but you
had some questions loaded up what do you
have I have thank you uh Radley are we
going to see things like hurricane
Seasons being extended and maybe moving
further north to begin with and our
Evolution as a species has been adapt
and survived what adaptions can we start
to implement now while all of your data
is getting harvested yeah so we got to
get going with adaptation right away at
the time of thinking oh we just reduce
our emissions and and we won't need to
adapt that's a false argument right
because partly because we have so many
vulnerable communities right now right
let's think about all our people with
the pre-existing health conditions heart
disease renal failure respiratory issues
um these people need help right now
um even before you think about heat wave
so what can we do everything in urban
areas from more cooling centers more
advisories getting the word out to
communities where maybe English isn't
first language about the dangers of
these of these heat waves as they
approach
um steps to increase shade we talked
about the radiant heating
um earlier those are some of the kind of
things we can do and I think also
accommodating
um as much as we can changes in the
practice schedules our time of day for
things like sports but also what about
all the farmers out there who are having
to work during these times
what you're suggesting is to use to what
you're suggesting is to use an acid rain
proof umbrella as the solution to the
acid rain
are you saying yeah no no and we just
have to so I don't call this I don't
call this adapting this is this is this
is suffering under it trying to mitigate
losses that's not adapting to it well
that's yeah and I'm glad you made that
point because all these attitude they're
not cost free right if it was easy to do
these things people would have done them
and as we come up with these adaptations
we got to make sure they don't lead to
the vulnerable suffering even more right
who's adapting first is it the wealthy
is it Venture capitalists who are
getting access to information about
both of those you know or the people
that starts or the countries that have
the most access to fresh water for
example that's the new is that the new
oil or the future yeah and and who often
yeah but everything you're saying is
it's what we call resilience which you
know people talk in this term resilience
because it sounds good and nobody knows
what the hell it is but that's what it
is everything you just said is what it's
about because we are kind of screwed
yeah nobody wants to say it but we are
kind of screwed and we have to do both
we have to have mitigation and we also
have to have adaptation at the same time
for sure we got to make sure we're doing
them in a sensible way we're there
operating at uh you know sort of against
each other how do we do it in a way
where the decisions we make for
adaptation mitigation work together
planting more trees you know for example
in in a lot of places but yeah I mean
basically it's a negative narrative in a
lot of ways right climate change faster
than we thought these impacts on systems
faster than we thought it the key
question is is there evidence out there
that maybe there are some
non-linearities working our in our favor
on the solution space right and that's
so that's what go back now and figure
those out okay yeah and then come back
to Star talk and say Here's a way that
we can never run away process that's in
our favor rather than one that'll render
us extinct or get rid of all of our
coastal cities right young people who
are you know gonna pick their colleges
pick their jobs based on whether
um those entities are reducing their
emissions thinking about resilience of
vulnerable communities cultural
investors right priorities yes yes right
yes investors people procuring all those
sorts of things yeah all right so we
gotta we gotta Land This Plane uh
Bradley just give us can you say
something positive before we go I think
it's that I mean my cliche would be the
course I teach at Columbia just seeing
over the last 10 years how students
nowadays really do you know pick their
colleges and their first jobs and where
they're going to invest their money on
whether entities care about about racial
Justice whether they're focused on
reducing emissions whether it's thinking
about their supply chains and their
workers and their vulnerabilities we're
getting there right that's just the
Ivory Tower but you know for seeing that
across Society I think we're a social
species and we can see change quickly
and what we heard about you know in the
first segment is a critical example that
we need what bud was describing the
Criterion you know to to you know go
viral is the wrong phrase for it but but
spread out that's beautiful Bradley I'm
glad you're capable of saying beautiful
things like that but it's not just yeah
all doomans so thank you and and then
you top it off with and by the way we're
all gonna die
but Radley thanks for sharing some of
your time with star talk and you're a
neighbor so we might attack you again
for some other ways you can contribute
to our intensely interested audience in
this topic so Radley do you have a
social media footprint that people can
follow
I do think I'm on Twitter at
radleyhorton and Bradley Horton okay I
will see what what gems you can share
with us but hopefully the advice on how
to mitigate all this so that there's a
world that our descendants can uh
inherit and not be ashamed of who left
it for them right so Gary Chuck good to
have you man
pleasure pleasure and Bradley like I
said we'll find you again we know where
you live okay thank you Neil deGrasse
types in here for StarTalk sports
edition as always I bid you to keep
looking up
foreign